[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the spring 2021 season of the saint
louis corporate chess league
in an unusual way as mike cummer
attempts to both
host and play for one of the teams
and now your host mike cummer
welcome to the corporate chess league
it's the spring league and this is
match number two i am your host
international arbiter michael j
cummer and as you see i'm not just
hosting
i'm not just analyzing but i'll also be
playing
and you say why does st louis chescalev
have a team
no i am playing for the merits
corporation
back in 1999 me and executive director
tony
rich both worked for quality controlled
services in sunset hills
a subsidiary of merits
so that's how i get to play tonight and
i will be on board one
playing the best player the highest
rated player
in the corporate chess league i will be
playing
agnati who leads doherty
so should be a good match hopefully
i won't humiliate myself but you never
know the faster i get done
the faster i can get on to analyzing the
rest of the show
so take the good with the bad
and look at the teams we have tonight in
no order in in
a perfectly random order it's not
alphabetical and it's definitely not by
uh
points all right we have you know what
i'll just name them uh
by the the standings here is the current
stance this is match number two of the
corporate chess league the spring league
we will play five matches and then all
culminate at the final four
so you want to be the top points teams
um after those five matches have
concluded
and then the last thursday in may
will uh will play we'll play the final
four
for the uh for the championship and
you'll get your name on the board
so there'll be two names that get their
name on the board this year one for the
spring league
one for the fall league so if you're so
interested if you want to your name
you know as one of these corporations
there's still time to sign up for the
fall league okay
and maybe the fall league will be in
person
maybe it will be virtual maybe it will
be this is a very
popular award uh a hybrid event so
we'll figure it out we got plenty of
time we're smart people we'll figure out
by that
all right but let's get to the current
standings
edward jones has 67 and a half points
merits has 53 and a half points
that's the team i'm playing for so i i
got to play board
2 last time around and went 4-0
even though a couple of those games were
pretty tough authority
doherty right behind so this is a huge
match
merits and dougherty jacketing for a
second place position
and the the loser of the of that match
might fall out of uh
out of the final four you never know
dougherty right behind with 50
wwt who loves to bring as many
players as possible you can bring up the
16 players
this time around they're only bringing
12 though they got 38 points they didn't
even win a game
last time but because they they brought
like the maximum last time
they uh they end up with 38 points
express scripts
37 and a half right behind they're in
that fifth spot so they got to step up
big tonight
bear has 33 enterprises the reigning
champion
of the corporate chess league is also
tied with bear for uh
sixth place with 33. arko has 28 in
their first appearance in the
corporate chess league so just because
you have a new team you can still be
competitive quick
ascension has three and umb has one the
way the scoring works in the uh
corporate chess league is
you know if you win a game you get a
point for your corporation okay that's
no matter what you get and obviously if
you draw you get uh
one grand prix point but here's how you
can get
the bundles and bundles of points if
your team
wins their match which could have four
players could have
eight players it just depends on the
matchup
um bottom line if you score more points
than your uh
your opposing corporation you get
20 bonus grand prix points so that's uh
that's pretty exciting and we actually
have a live game now round one is at 6
15. i am awaiting my challenge
from the 2200
agonati from uh good old
doherty so i am awaiting that challenge
so as soon as i get the challenge
i will accept it and then we'll be off
to the races it's game 10
no delay no increment so i have to be uh
and if you are watching either on
youtube or twitch
we are simulcasting tonight uh please
do not uh mention any moves for me
please
okay that that would not be fun
so if you guys could uh not do that that
would be great
i don't know how often i'll be able to
to look over
and if you do want to follow my game so
obviously you can just follow online or
on chess.com i
am my username is so much better than
you i made the account when i was very
juvenile
even more juvenile than i am now if you
can't believe
it all right so let's see let's see all
right
great overcomer is he is are we related
all right
he who says good luck so so great
hopefully i can overcome
the rating disparity and everything can
uh
can go well for merits team competitions
are always fun
you get invested in it and invest it in
your uh
your your teammates and how they're
doing and uh
you know you know that was that was
the greatest thing ever we got a a match
clinching
victory by uh by one of our
our guys uh gary mendel 66
he got the big stalemate draw so you
play to the bitter end in this in this
you should make it a habit to play at a
bitter end in all
in all your chess games but especially
in team competitions
you gotta you gotta put it all on the
line there
uh
good evening i'm manny l p
i love the uh the emoji mr mortar
twenty twenty i am i am still awaiting a
challenge i am in the chess.com
uh
chess.com live i'm just waiting
maybe i can just go and challenge him
and
maybe i don't know
a rad a-i-g-b-o-j-e
he's here waiting for who so i am
playing uh a match i am playing for the
marriage corporation i am playing
against uh
the boardward of doherty who is 22 45
and here we go he challenged me and i am
accepting and we're off to the races and
he's got even better since
uh today he's won even more games
all right let's see if he's going to
fall for that comer sicilian he does not
he's smart man smart man
he probably did his prep he did it's
prep
but i don't mind this at all hopefully
let me do this
he does got to get rid of this night i
hate this night
all right
all right so far so good i cannot
complain
well maybe a little ambitious but
whatever
all right hey hey you know it's move
whatever eleven i've already made uh
and i'm doing well on time and
i put this guy to the test a little bit
yup that's what i figured oh but it
allows f4 maybe i'll play h5
all right all right i'm not i'm not too
too
okay that makes sense oh so now if he
plays
f4 i just have to go back
what a bummer oh but i can play
king here and not let him get bishop h6
probably not the best move of all time
but can't complain
if you are in the chat uh please no
kabitsing
please no kabitsky i think he's tempting
me to play a5
but i'm not gonna take the bait
oh no oh that's where that's when i
i'm done in i didn't see that my pawn
was pinned to my dude
but maybe it's not the end of the world
or maybe it is i don't know
it's not ideal i'll tell you that
gosh darn it i should have just when he
played a3 i should have just played
queen c7
right away i did not see
i mean and that's what i always stress
like always always know what's in the
same line
as your pieces how hard is it
so a bishop was in the line the rook was
in the line
get him out of there
what is in the same land as my kings
there's some pawns and some more pawns
so that's good that's good
this bishop is attacking this pawn
oh but i got my bishop on the same line
as this night maybe we can generate some
tactics
that way
you know what i'll just take it if
you're going to give me
multiple times to take this i'll do it
all right what else is going on i still
got this f4 threat going
i don't know if i even care about it
what's he waiting for i could play b5
and lose my pawn
so do i want the rook on the h
file or the a file
god only knows or maybe i could play
knight to g
all right let's go let's just move it or
lose it
do i really want my rook or do i want to
play e6
and never let his knight come in
all right i don't know
sam shanklin says you ever move a pawn
guess what they're never going back
never going back so you got to be
careful of your pawn moves
he wrote that book about his uh pawns
right before he won the u.s chess
championship
any mini money mo i'll let the computer
figure this one out for me okay
so don't say the computer didn't help me
today oh okay
all right um maybe my other knight wants
to go there
all right
he's going for it
oh now i'm gonna have an isolated pawn
all right this is why i'm not going to
do anything about this
and just hope it works out i just hope
it works
play a little hope chess can't my knight
just go back now
yeah now look who's the fool you just
let my knight go
right back
and d4 does not work hopefully
so i guess it really didn't matter if i
put on d7 or c6 because i was just going
back anyway
all right seven minutes i got seven
minutes to work with and we're
good pace for this game last last week
our last two weeks last in match number
one i it was taking me so long to make
like the first like 10
12 moves it was embarrassing but this
at least i'm playing at a decent pace
maybe my moves are
sub-optimal but what else do you expect
you know
so hopefully my team merits
is doing a-okay we'll get to their games
i cannot really follow any games while i
am playing
apparently well let's see if that's true
nope i can i i can go but i don't really
want to follow anybody else's game right
now
chess halky is playing for the reigning
champions enterprise also
on board two tonight enterprise is
taking on
wwt rook b to b1 so you're just going
backwards
do i understand that do i even want to
understand it or do i just want to play
d5
count the pieces count the pieces
i don't think there's enough pieces
oh my gosh where do i want to go where
do i want to go
well the rook needs to stay on the f
file
i don't know what work the c8 does but
just maintains the position
maybe i should have played rick to d ah
now he's are you kidding me
or am i really going to go back to the
so if he plays knight takes i'm in
trouble right
all right i'm just going to say i got a
pass pawn
that's all i'm going to say he can
disconnect it with b6 but
hey if you really want to go that route
more power to you buddy
it's either i'm playing b6 or he's
playing b6
who's it gonna be it's a big showdown
but he's he's got the draw so
i mean i can't believe he wouldn't play
b6 in this position
all right well i'm playing it you can
play g4 all you want
you play g4 i'm taking it and then
you'll take it okay okay
oh two on one
this is actually a-okay for me because i
got
this night hopefully i'm i'm moving back
the right night
gosh am i moving back up or do i want
this knight back down there
yeah now you weren't doing anything up
there and now i'll apply knight to there
and then i'm i i think i actually am
winning
oh he's got tactics i think i've moved
the wrong
night he's got some tactics
because if if i play knight c5 he takes
i take pawn take
i don't need to explain it to everybody
right now but so
i could do it a little weakness do a
little weakness
all right i'm i really like my position
especially since i'm playing a
264 if i can if i can if i can
do something here i could just start
pushing my pawn to glory
do i really want to play rook to h8
i don't think i do
i could just play my knight back to d7
can i get my knight here somehow some
way
because pawn takes pawn takes and then
i mean he's going to play bishop g5 no
matter what here
so maybe if i play king to g8
and then he plays this bishop back
that's all i got so i knew he was
playing there i told you
so here we go
knight to f6 draw you think he'll go for
a draw
just to be funny offer to draw
for the draw oh maybe he'll go for it
well you better figure something out
then
all right no he declined to draw he
declined to draw
oh he just won my rook oh he just run my
rook
come on chess.com give me that freeway
oh shucks
well at least at least i can play no
holds bart for a second here
alexander sucks really scholarly
[Music]
you can't make this stuff up hey are you
guys having the quants tomorrow
we sure are we sure should we take a
live call
maybe he was just calling to uh to troll
me
i can't believe you fell for that fork
dude
i can't
and believe
just go get a queen
hey alexander slackish yeah rook
you guys you guys were really letting me
down tonight rook
all right let's get on with the show
yep i'm three away from a queen you
heard it here first i'm three away
i am three away
all right i'm not bluffing i'm not
bluffing
i'm very excited plus my knight can hop
in here
maybe do something shucks
that could be the end of the line here
i do not want to do that i've thought
about it but i do not
want to do that
oh here we go oh my gosh all right all
right
things are looking up for michael comer
i'm going to get my knight right here
and there's nothing he can do about it
it's going to take him an hour to try to
win that pawn too
and he's only got five minutes so
i like i like my chances here i could go
here
or there
all right so he's just giving me this
pawn
so i might as well take it
all right things are looking way up for
me
i love my knights too so
and i'm threatening the fork now
i know my knight is under attack
oh what a nifty nifty move oh that would
just lose my
queen oh but then i could have
two nights
two nights
oh but is my knife going to get trapped
by that queen
probably
shucks
oh rook takes us pretty good oh but okay
so he
math my king can get over to protect
that pawn
i don't think i can i'll give up on that
attempt
all right 106 106.
all right my king is in he's in
oh my gosh and now i'm just three away
that other way i know i just gotta get
rid of this pawn
gosh darn it do i want to take that
and now i got this passer geez
things are looking up in the world
there's really nothing i can do about
that
pretty good move pretty good move sorry
i got 30 seconds
dang good move
i gotta just try to checkmate this guy
and i'm not even joking around
my two nights my two nights we got him
in the corner here
somehow some way we got to get a
checkmate got to get a checkmate
we're not thinking of anything else just
checkmate here
stranger things have happened stranger
things
oh now i'm even closer oh come on check
mate
oh could this be checkmate
oh my god who's calling me now
oh my guy's in a pin
i just gotta pre-move now and just hope
hope somehow somewhere i got checkmate
oh it's not checking me oh please say
this is checkmate oh
so close so close
so close oh no
oh my gosh but i almost got it huh
oh that was so close
gosh that was so close
oh man what a game
and people are texting me at the end
oh at that point he's asking me where he
wants
food from he had all night to figure it
out
uh right when i was about ready to check
made him
man was that almost checkmate
booyah
all right we're supposed to play
cancel challenge
can you challenge
oh man i really thought i had it at the
buzzer
yep you can always be the optimist
always be the optimist
all right here we go this wants the
[Music]
rematch
play a little d4
we'll just get this going here
and why even pretend
why even pretend
hopefully my teammates
are doing well we'll
follow them oh chess hockey
for enterprise got the uh got a draw
against the board 2 of wwt
maybe we can get some results in
momentarily here
all right it's really not the way to
play but i don't really care
that's the way i play that's the way i
play i usually like to have my bishop
and queen
opposite so and get the big checkmate
here
i'll just pre-move it just in case uh
chess.com wants to be funny
let me do one free jump that didn't let
me
oh well i didn't think it was going to
work
all right so i've got got a little
and i can i agnati
is a is a is a
is a man i can confirm that yep
he's a mister should i give him the the
ridiculous
check the answer is no why don't i just
have
or do i want to break out with e4
probably not but i'll do it anyway
getting a little antsy getting a little
antsy you probably wanted to prepare it
with rookie one rook c1a3
h3 i wanna
get on with the show here still kind of
amped up from uh
round one where i thought i might have
had an amazing comeback at the buzzer
but it was not meant to be as is rook
covered my uh he covered the checkmating
square
so
how do i take with the knight obviously
right
but now his e5 doesn't look as strong as
it did
a minute before so at least it doesn't
look as intimidating to me and that's
all that really matters because
chess is a sport one-on-one mano amano
you control the pieces
nobody's telling you what to do and
people that
play like that that's why the number one
rule in the chess club is
no kabit scene whether you're playing
over the board
online casual game
on the street that's a different thing
but in the club
at home when you're playing just no
kabit scene from any source
unless you're playing correspondence
chess and then then everybody knows
i don't know if correspondence chess
even uh exists anymore
through the mail all right so he plays
it anyway
not intimidated by it not intimidated
but maybe i should have been
now my rook is under attack
everybody see that good
but he's got this guy helping him out so
now where does this work
this work actually wants to go on d1 i
still want to play h3 sometime
oh he could play oh i hope he plays
well do i hope he plays bishop okay
he might play bishop f5
all right my position's looking great
oh he just played bishop to e6 oh
because i guess he knew i wanted to play
queen to see
you're attacking my pawn i don't really
like that
all right make a little look for your
king even though i would still be
checkmated if it was a back row mate
here
so
all right doing all right on time eight
minutes eight minutes
look f to e8
do i just want to try to trade off
everything
yeah yeah hey hey thanks for texting me
with uh five seconds to go on the clock
i thought i had
checked mate for the delusions of
granger
i thought i was getting a what was it a
preemptive text oh you're so good you're
so good
well alexander sakashvili calls and
tells me
what a dope i am for falling for the
fork in the beginning of the game
oh i don't know
it's on you just make sure it's i
am for uh for the big holiday i am uh
40 days or actually it's 46 days of uh
just vegetarian diet the fish diet so
make sure i can go somewhere i'm able to
get some grilled cheese from medina or
something
i don't care
you couldn't wait till halftime to ask
me now i'm down a minute on time
where does my knight even want to be
does it even matter anymore
all right get this bishop's gotta go
hopefully my rook doesn't fall at the
end of all this
that won't even let me make the move
it's so bad
because now he's got
but luckily my queen protects this night
also i'd be in a lot of trouble
and as you saw how great my nights were
last game this dark squared bishop is
probably going to be way
better than my night in the end game
especially because i have all my pawns
on dark squares
uh oh a red alert hopefully my night
doesn't fall somehow
for some tactic here doesn't look like
it will but
and my knight has no good outpost so
i'm in some trouble i'm in some trouble
okay trade
and then he'll have the d file
i don't think i can trade well he's
going to get the defile no matter what
he's getting the d file
there's not a dang thing i can do about
it
however however
i've got this really good move here
thank you
if i didn't see this move i would have
never played the trade
queen c2 best move on the board i
guarantee it
oh man all right threatening
nothing oh oh he could play down here uh
bishop
but that actually doesn't threaten
anything
get out of the pin but now i'm
susceptible to a lot of checks
and i mean a lot of checks
just walk into the checks i'll take them
take any check you can get
oh shucks how did i not see that coming
well that's the end of this game it was
a good run it was a good run
i was distracted by everybody but
well just try to go into a losing end
game and hope
shucks
make the king a warrior
hmm
let's hurry up here let's hurry up four
minutes to go that's how it got me
last time i was down on time i only died
on time because i blew like 90 seconds
with a
on a spiel
two minutes i spent on that move
unbelievable
i mean this is not the easiest uh game
for him to win
but it was nice not the toughest either
f5 i was hoping he'd do that oh
i'm tempted get that passer
can i hold on to that passer or can he
get it with
all my checks
i might just walk in to check mate here
huh
well i definitely don't want to do that
or else i'm lost
let's just go for it just get that get
that passer and hope that uh
i mean it worked out last but it didn't
work out but
it made it pretty competitive
hopefully i can hold on to it
now if i can hold on to this pass or if
he gives it to me
i've got a chan a good chance to draw oh
my gosh
how did i not see the check
okay so he's checking me now so he
didn't want my knight
all right all right i'll take this now
i'm
playing my knight up here and threading
checkmate or something
and i've got oh i've got queen check on
the way anyway
so if i go here or we can take the pawn
but then i'm
well why let them have the pawn
let's just get on with the show
all right this is this is a okay i just
need to start
playing faster though if i want to have
any any kind of chats
i do not want to let them have the jeep
on
my king's gun going around in circles
old path for uh wwt
scores one and a half out of two against
the reigning champions boards
two chess hulky for enterprise
very interesting that's the only other
results we have so far in
the books tonight we will do extensive
recaps
once this game has concluded uh oh
did i just fall for checkmate no if i
did i did
oh well he's gonna get my knight
that was a long way to get my knight
oh my gosh that was cool
i i did not see that that was check and
that's that's going to be it
unbelievable well
i got to play onto the bitter end now
but we can start we can start reading
off some results while this is going on
though
who knows maybe it gets a night fork or
something or
at this point i am just playing for a
stalemate you'd be like
what are you doing while you're giving
away all your pieces well one there's
probably nothing i can do about it
anyway
two i'm just go i'm just in pure
stalemate mode right now
very disappointing i did not see that
that was a check until it was too late
i want to hide behind these pawns and
hope something strange happens
but i think this guy's probably too good
to let that happen but you gotta play
the mate you gotta play the checkmate
that's the name of the game
all right good game
gg uh i did not live he lived up to his
rating congratulations
uh ogdenat the boardward authority
scoring
2-0 against the board one of merits
the very own state chess champion of
1998
of missouri the scholastic state
champion
not not the real state champion that was
another
master from the other side of the state
ron luther and he also beat me in round
one
okay so these are the updated standings
is this correct uh
so this is unofficial these are the
unofficial results of round one
and remember you get the
20-point bonus for winning
so i don't know i don't know so he's got
ascension with 20
express scripts with 19 and a half
essentially doesn't look right
unless he added that the bonus already
because
okay so i think ascension's
oh i know i know how our ascension has
20 points let's end the mystery right
now
ascension has a 10 point buy
next round express scripts got because
we had an uneven number of teams even
though it
i know it doesn't look uneven just trust
me it is uneven
we only have nine four player teams we
have one three player team
that is not playing as a team they're
just playing for points
that's umb who got on the board with one
so
ascension so none of the none of the
bonus points for either a win or draw
have been added
however ascension started with a 10.5
for round two
and uh express scripts also started with
a 10-point buy
for round number one because they they
essentially got the buy
look at ascension though 40 points
well well 40 points it is
36 points for edward jones edward jones
just they win
every time except for the
big championship the final four of uh
2021 john warrior time boyer
john warrior time boyer checkmated the
board
one of edward jones in the armageddon
match with .3 seconds
dashing their dreams
so let's check out uh tonight's game
your opponent played well that's all you
have to say to me uh the
tough one kid better luck next time
man well are there any
i don't think there aren't any games
that probably was that one pretty long
um game report
oh i played a hundred rapid games uh
excellent
i i rather see the the the first
one so i played 85 percent accuracy
and my opponent actually made a blunder
huh
but he played 91.6 percent
that check was a blunder
because yeah they just want them to take
it yeah
well yep let's check out let's check out
the other game here
well maybe we don't have time see if i
actually had a checkmate or anything
let's let's check out my first game
against ogdent
see if i messed up or maybe if i had
something so good at the end
because i could have sworn i had
checkmate at the end
but it was not meant to be
a 22-60 well there's only one way to
find out corey one
five six there's only one way to find
out
so we both had a missed win in the game
oh man one player was winning then gave
it all away
gosh so at what point
did uh
what point did i have a comeback win
here
yep plus oh man
i would have been checkmate well he
would could have gone there
i would have gone there
now under promote to a knight and i'll
get another check
h1 equals queen draw you know
oh well well we're probably about ready
to start round
two let me jump on the
call again you want to take a really
really quick break ben simon while i
jump on this uh zoom call to see if i
can challenge
all right we'll be right back
alex kirford i'm the founder of the
corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to the pandemic
in covet 19 we were able to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis it was a
lot of fun
had a high level of engagement and
people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on
the corporate chess league once a month
here at edward jones we actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to associates all over north
america
i have a really good friend in the
phoenix area who's passionate about
chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page and be able to see
and interact with each other in a
virtual way
and then partnering with chess.com we're
able to provide
the the actual tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of
you know uh rib each other a little bit
and and it is a little friendly banter
which we love and
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going
that makes for a lot of fun for people
to be able to
see how their friends how their
colleagues are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
for to have motivation sometimes we can
get down on things
having an outlet where competition
can still be involved in your life
having an
outlet where you can still have
networking with your colleagues
has really been a key part of the
success
of the corporate chess league it has
been really fun to be able to not only
get to know the people in my own firm
better and share that that similar
passion but also get to know people from
several different firms here in in the
st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league both here in the
st
louis area and beyond we're looking
forward to a great season
in 2021 if you or your company
is interested in being a part of the
corporate chess league
you can go to www.st
club and get more information
we'd love to have you be a part of the
competition
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces
with state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon
all right welcome back to the corporate
chess league this is the spring league
match number two i am once again
1998 missouri scholastic state champion
mike cummer
a player in it and that an analysis
if i can say that word that's a tough
one
and a host or whatever just pile all the
titles on i'm also an international
orbiter
and we have the standings from round
number one
ascension because of their by this round
we already gave them the 10 points
so they are leading the way with 40
points
edward jones they just win
win win 36 points
wwt has 31 with all their players
they borrowed a dozen of them this time
around express scripts
29 and a half so they must have got they
they were given that 10 points they must
have uh
got nine and a half points in their in
their match and they
boosted and got another ten so okay so
they're there and fourth doherty who
beat
uh merits who i am playing for tonight
they have 26 enterprise the reigning
champion
who coming into tonight only had 33
points and they've only added
three and a half points in round one to
that total
versus wwt not looking good
what's going on with enterprise
merits came up a little bit short
two points i would have had to beat the
master back to back games
in order for us to just eke out a draw
so i can't really feel
too bad against that but you go as your
leader goes right
i'm not their leader but they're bored
we missed we were missing our board one
tonight i'm more of a board two kind of
guy
oh man now my queen's in trouble this is
not
good and then
rounding out is bear umb and then who
are we are playing right now arko
so hopefully uh marist can score big
against arko
and salvage something we were in second
place coming into
this uh this match but
we'll be lucky if we leave in even the
final four
we're all shooting for that the final
four the last
thursday in may because then pretty much
everything's clear
clear off the table and it's just final
four mile romano
and and the winner will be declared that
night
this is not the best game i've ever
played in my life i can tell you that
right now
i'm in a lot of trouble if i can sneak
in knight
to g4 i'll be up i'll be i'll be down
tonight if i do that
oh my gosh
this is not good i might not even get uh
i might not even get a
i might not even get a
wow this is not good
well that's why it's a team match okay
you gotta win for me team
i'm negative a thousand right now
well maybe i can at least get a pawn for
it
so if he plays f4 i can take the po
actually
is is isn't well
it could be worse let's just say it
could be worse
i thought f4 was just going to crush me
but we'll see remember i'm a fighter
he's a fart
get him down and maybe he can make the
best of a bad situation
but that's a pretty bad situation
come on merits
i mean he's got bishop f4 he's got
knight b5 he's got
f4
but hopefully i'll get this bishop for
it
and let's go from there
and then i'm gonna get this knight for
it too actually this this might actually
work out for me even better i was
i meant i was negative a thousand by you
know
the black pieces are have the edge by
negative a thousand
i'm gonna get all his pieces and this
knight's never coming out
oh i hope he blocks with the rook
then i'll really be up a thousand points
or did i luck out that's why you never
resign in chess even though
you think you lost
hey maybe maybe you're bad at
calculating you know
because i went from uh from thinking i
was just
dead lost uh crushing
even even the scoreboard's gonna say it
pretty soon after i
get his uh get his guy actually in this
position i want to trade queens
bad if if he plays king h1
i'll play that one i'll have a more
active king two he's just gonna have two
rooks to
a million of my pieces
and the way to trap this is just play b6
bishop b7
and go from there
you would never play bishop to b6 and
bail them out here
just calmly go back all the way back
i'm plus two i'm soon to be plus
five he could he could obviously take my
pawn on b6 here
with the knight so he'll be plus four
and i have three minor pieces
against uh against two rooks
oh check oh i didn't even realize that
was chuck too so he couldn't even get
the pawn up so now i'm plus five
all right i'm really liking this now
oh and i got the fork
wow what a turnaround from
thinking he was dead lost to
dead winner
gg rematch
wow he got bailed out that that game
hopefully my teammate now i am rounder
he actually won the uh
the brilliancy prize in november
and that was given to him by caleb denby
and then uh
gary mendel 66 won the brilliancy prize
last month for his uh
triumphant stalemate
so we got some players on our team we
just need to
need to come through in a clutch uh
today so hopefully
hopefully i can contribute my two points
this time around
but you never know
that's why we played the games this is
the corporate
chess league the spring league
very exciting match number two
oh maybe i can play this uh this trick
i like to play bishop here bishop back
queen c2
checkmate
that was
oh just play a little more solid this
time around actually get
castled i did get castled i know in the
second game of the match
yeah maybe i won't get castle maybe i'll
play king to e2 here
oh
i needed to play bishop takes knight
first oh
michael michael michael
yeah i had one chance and i
blew it
just refuse the castle
that's a good move by him
okay so he's attacking my rook oh but i
can
oh do not threaten checkmate
it looked tempting it looked tempting
but i would have got
forked for the second time today
or actually the third time but i
i like that i like that knight c7 check
fork
it ended up going pretty working out
pretty well for me
maybe i can try to trap this knight
even though he's protected by the his
own guy
i like that move i like it i like it
maybe rick the d1 what is bet no
i like this better than work to d1
because now he's got to go
back oh yo nope oh
oh oh all right
hopefully this just hangs a piece
well it doesn't cause he's got check
oh now this is
tactics time buddy
yes because if i play b4 he's got this
funny
check so we prevent the check
and triple team
i mean it's not like the toughest tactic
to see but
if it helps the team it helps the team
all right
yeah just take with the real keep it
simple all right
this ending should be pretty simplistic
but hey it's a team event so i do not
blame this gentleman
in the world for want to play it out
because who knows
if he can trade all these pawns on the
queen side
and leave me with this guy and run back
to
his corner it's a draw so
so let's make sure that that does not
happen tonight
and plus i don't know what i'm doing so
he's got that going
and plus mouse lips i mean any anything
can happen on chess.com it's the
corporate chess league
anything can happen
but i just hope i get the w for the team
give them a check
oh
very exciting games all right
we'll be able to watch a lot of the
other games
as soon as this this has concluded
i'll be checking out
yeah yeah and that's another thing you
always want to check how many bars they
got if
if uh what kind of connection they have
you know there's a lot of ways to win or
draw on chess.com so
you gotta gotta watch out for that
all right now it's time to go get these
pawns
yeah and i might be too over anxious
with all these pre-moves too so
and my king is cut off he's out of the
game my king
okay i'm not gonna win this pawn so i
might as well just
just face the facts
oh i should have taken with them
well actually this works out just fine
oh he's trying to get that stalemate
trying to get that stalemate
checkmate all right
oh yeah okay all right so let's get to
let's get to some
games here
how do we go how do we go
what do we do play some live chats
we do have a game chess hulky for uh
enterprise
but we gotta we gotta see what what what
some of my teammates are up to and
merits we gotta win this game
i am rounder he's our board two tonight
how about hashtag follow
maybe uh our tournament director our
great tournament director we're
so happy to have him oh i am rounder
is uh not playing so
maybe he's got some updates on the big
spreadsheet here
let's see what nick has cooking in this
one
round two oh we got a lot of results in
already
uh so wwt is playing bear
they are doing very well they're already
up three and a half to a half
doherty oh that
they ran into edward jones so you know
what that score's gotta be
it's now six to two
edward jones and one two three four five
so they won that edward jones has
officially won that
match so you can give him uh 20 points
because there's only they
fits five against five so once you get
five and a half you win
so there's no drama in that one merits
against arko
all right merits back on the board
i of course uh barely got my two points
well i want to see that game report if i
was just crushed in that opening
um i am rounder i bought two
he won oh he won by forfeit un
un unfortunately yeah in this corporate
chess league
once this master sheet is done by
nicholas risco that the td
uh anything after that it's just
four fits uh and then uh
oh our ring or other ringer gary mendel
66 he got a point
so we're at five and a half to a half so
we have officially won
that match so you can give us merits the
20 points
enterprise you know yeah
that yeah they knew they had to do a
little bit better this time around
and they have uh five points against
express
scripts and express scripts has two
oh we got another forfeit in the in some
of the extra games too but that's all
right
all right let's see some uh let's see
some games what's the most
competitive match we got going well
enterprise
has one two three four to two and you
need
you need six to win so let's see what
our uh
see what the hero of uh
the final four john boyer is up to
playing board one oh he already won his
games
oh big daddy jazz 64 is playing from
texas tonight
so let's see how he's doing he won his
first game and if
if uh if you guys have like a
a best game award or are thinking hey
that this
this that's the best game i've seen
please uh put it in the comments here
please
and uh let me and i'll take a i'll take
a good look at it
because i was obviously preoccupied with
my games against the master in the first
round
and uh
and so forth
so if you have a best game you want me
to look at and you're the first to
respond
and they all need to respond you might
win it by default
so
all right
yeah yeah good game uh
yeah i wanna i wanna i wanna take a very
quick look at
my my first round game against uh
the the first round or the first board
from uh
orco let's see uh
let's just check it out check it out
oh team comer ben ben simon's on there
all right
let's check it out
was he in trouble was he in trouble no
brilliant moves i don't believe
it no brilliant moves
all right that was a mistake all right
queen to f6 is a big mistake oh and
right here
attack and threaten the big check that's
what they want you to do
or just oh or knight to d5
bishop g7 is best all right bishop e3 is
best
knight h6 is a mistake knight d5 is best
queen e5 is best f4 is a mistake so i
get the
check and right here they want you to
just protect the knight
interesting
and then so yeah
yeah yeah that's why hopefully next
month i can just uh
just analyze the games and and get all
the best games going and not uh
not have to uh not have to play but here
we go
we got chess hulky he looks like he's up
by
even though he's only up one with the
scoreboard
they just had him up by
12 points if he plays this
nifty knight f3 check now this is
according to the computer
i did i would never have saw it oh but
maybe well well you got to know what's
in the lines
so after takes you can you can just take
with the rook oh and then the
bye bye queen so let's see he got a
reprieve here
let's see if uh
a warner 21 rookie three it looks like
that stops the check
wow so chess hulky
but but don't count him out
you know he's he's he's going he's
trying to become a chess
expert with uh with a with a win here
they'll probably give him a point for
defeating the 1282 maybe
but they're both in the danger zone both
under
two minutes on the clock
even though chess hockey is plus one
they still like uh
they're still giving him a plus 2.6
advantage
very interesting oh let's check out uh
the the other guy from
from merits real quick garymindel66
let's see it see how that game's going
so gary mendel has the white pieces
they're saying it's a draw they both
have equal material they both have
three pawns and a rook and a knight
you got to be careful though you got to
be careful
yeah this is a tough one
yo he's got the passer he's got the
passer look out
he needs to play rook check here oh that
even works better
i wouldn't like work check and then get
behind the pawn
or maybe even have time to win this pawn
yeah they like rook to e7 check yeah and
that that's another
move i was just going to just get that
pawn out of here
and then win that other and then win the
a pawn and then
you know because it's very tough to
checkmate a rook and a knight against a
lone rook you can you can easily trade
off this pawn
with your two pawns so gary
mindle might have to do that but let's
go down to this game
oh somebody's got made in six nobody
knows who though
and they don't know either somebody had
made in six
so when they say made in six who does
that help
how would somebody have mate and six in
this position
are white pieces working that that good
together
this is anybody's game now
the bar is going back and forth back and
forth
oh he's got a big check on the big
check
yeah it's just it's game 10 no delay no
increment so
oh and there it goes there it goes
chess hulky's gonna pull it out with 25
seconds to go
at least you would think oh and he won
the bishop right off the bat
yeah run that other pawn
get move that move this f pawn move got
to move that f pawn
or else how are you going to get a
stalemate without the f point
now we can find this mate
all right score another point for
enterprise so we should be uh
this might be one of the last games
going here let's see if uh
every point counts even though if you
already get that 20
uh however many points uh gary mendel 66
they all add up to so those uh final
four grand prix points so
old loser knocked off big daddy jazz 64.
he got his revenge
but it looks like enterprise with chess
hockey's win
two three four five wins
oh but they need they need
five and a half so let's check out uh
another game from uh enterprise match
oh oh it hasn't been updated with chess
hockey's win that did clinch it it did
clinch it
they they now have the six points so
chess hockey's one did clinch the match
for enterprise they will be receiving
20 bonus points
how did this one end so quick
knight f5 check another check
there goes the pawn train in the rooks
oh and the the
there goes the knight and there goes the
pawn
there goes the other pawn and he's just
racing it up
and he gets the checkmate good job
gary mendel 66.
all right so do we have any comments in
the youtube
section of of who should be getting the
uh
the big prize
okay all right
a a draw against agnati
i don't like well i did give it to uh
gary mendel 66 so maybe i'll take a look
at that
let's take a look at uh tommy's game
against
kyqz and then we'll see if we even have
to take a look at a draw
anyway well we'll see
all right actually this might be the
faster way to do this
believe it or not
um this is tough
all right but he's figuring it out he's
figuring it out
a platinum member i'm also a platinum
member of uh
chess.com it's a it's very good to be
able to go over and analyze your games
and and do all the good stuff
so let's check it out can we can we see
some games
all right his first game against k-way
yeah he said his first game right my
first game okay
now i don't know if you get a brilliancy
praise
if you don't win no but one player was
winning but then gave it away
all right analysis
so tommy is playing with the white
pieces
against kyqz and kyqz was playing for
ascension they're on board one
all right b5 he's going places he's
going places
all right knight attacks the night
captures
knights coming up that's an excellent
move according to the computer
doubles up the rooks how can that be a
mistake
all right attacks the bishop bishop
retreats
knight takes with check oh there goes
the pawn
oh but oh that might have been a mouse
slip i wonder
even though serum bishop f6 is excellent
why wouldn't you go all the way to g7
what am i missing
oh you got this nifty bishop takes d6
move wow wow so if kyqz saw
that move
that is pretty impressive
rick attacks who
a missed win
b7 is best
big check
f6 never play f6
wow just queen to g4 it's yelling about
it or rook g7 i
i mean any move is good here yeah
wow you're so close oh can't you just
get a check mate oh they they even what
they even say the second best move is
rook takes f6
here which makes a lot of sense rook
takes f6 if you take back it's going to
be check
king moves anywhere check mate on g7 wow
gosh but that's the move i was going to
play
bishop g7 how does this guy survive
oh yeah when you're when you're on the
attack
you never ever want to trade pieces
moves like
well i was going to say queen h7
that doesn't really give you that big of
an advantage but
wow you kind of just let them off the
hook but you still have all these pawns
though
big check
whose pawn is going to be faster i think
i know the answer oh
yeah you gotta you gotta swing your rook
over
but i i think at that point it's too
late
and uh that's uh but that was a good
good move by ky
q z to see that move maybe we got time
to take one quick look at uh
vishal's game hopefully and then we'll
see
um
we'll tally up the final standings in
just a minute and and then
and then proclaim a winner
yeah i'm still here
is this me all right so let's see
agnandi
his draw oh oh wish draw
are you mean in the second draw
or this draw
if he shall rate it 800 what a comeback
let's check it out let's check it out we
should almost have the
the final results here
oh and then we'll add up the uh the
scores from last time around two
let's see this great draw
oh missed wind
draw yeah
all right all right so you want to take
a really quick
break ben simon and then we'll uh we'll
announce the winners from tonight
and then we'll have the uh the grand
grand prix point totals
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis it was a
lot of fun
had a high level of engagement and
people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide the
the actual uh tournament and and how the
competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of
you know rib each other a little bit and
and it is a little friendly banter which
we love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going
that makes for a lot of fun for people
to be able to
see how their friends how their
colleagues are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
to have motivation sometimes we can get
down on things having an
outlet where competition can still be
involved in your life having an outlet
where you can still have
networking with your colleagues has
really been
a key part of the success of the
corporate chess league
it has been really fun to be able to not
only get to know the people in my own
firm better and share that that similar
passion
but also get to know people from several
different
firms here in in the st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league both here in the
st
louis area and beyond we're looking
forward to a great season in 2021
if you or your company is interested
in being a part of the corporate chess
league you can go to
www.stlouischessclub.org
and get more information we'd love to
have you be a part of the competition
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility will feature new
ground-level classrooms supporting
players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow even greater community
engagement
in the great game of chess as a proud
resident of the central west end
neighborhood
for over a decade our hope is to build
upon our investment
into the community and solidify st louis
as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination for lovers of the sport
we look forward to seeing you in our new
space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 us chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup saint louis rapid and
blitz and more
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis it was a
lot of fun
had a high level of engagement and
people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual our audience has grown
we absolutely love the corporate chess
league i can tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on
the corporate chess league once a month
here at edward jones we actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual uh tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of uh you know
uh rib each other a little bit and and
it is a little friendly banter which we
love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going
that makes for a lot of fun for people
to be able to
welcome back to the corporate chess
league it's the spring league match
number two of five and then they'll all
culminate
at the final four the last
thursday in may
and these are the grand prix standings
let's get to the standings from
tonight's actions
first they do it again they do it again
edward jones with 72
points followed closely
by rock harris's wwt
he got a dozen people to play and they
got 65 and a half
points then ascension
who may or may not have the uh the grand
prize
brilliancy winner express scripts 33 and
a half
enterprise comes in
fifth with 29 and a half
the team i i uh
i championed on board one we had a rough
start in game one
had to play a master but we salvaged
ourselves
came in sixth place with 28 and a half
points
doherty 28 points so look how close i
mean
every point counts in this corporate
chess league
and then rounding up is bear umb and
arko
all right so i have the unofficial i
want to stress that
unofficial cumulative standings too
for right now okay so
leading the league which will be no
surprise as they won
match one of the spring league and match
two of the spring league
edward jones with 177 and a half
grand prix points in second place
103 and a half points is wwt
merits held on to a final four spot
we did drop out a notch uh this time
around but
we got 82 points followed closely
by doherty who also slipped uh
a spot but there with 78 points
they have uh if the playoffs started the
day they'd be
in the final four good for them
and then rounding out the field fifth
place express scripts with 71
sixth place enterprise 62 and a half so
they they have some work to do the
reigning champion so
they did get off to a little bit of a
slow start
uh last year in the middle of the year
they kind of tailed off a little bit but
then they came charging back in a big
way made the playoffs
the the final uh the final round of the
season and then and then won it all of
course with uh
john boyer's armageddon heroics
all right so and then seventh place
ascension they had a great showing
tonight
with they're in seventh place with 48
points eighth place is bear with 36 and
a half points umb
uh arko actually is in ninth place with
29 points and then umb
rounds off the field with four points
okay
so who won the grand
champion brilliancy prize which is a
free grand master
lesson game of the night
tommy arco you did it you did it
and we will also be giving away
uh to ky cusey of ascension
you both played a heck of a game that's
the night
oh hugh middlebrooks guess what you both
get
you both you both uh contributed
tommy played hard almost got that
checkmate
and then kyqz never gave up never
surrendered
and uh his team did great tonight so
congratulations you will both be winning
a grand master lesson in april
this is mike cummer signing off for the
corporate chess league
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club
you